I didn't have to stop she gave me the
mom look so I did I thought yeah I was
like I'm messing it up right now oh you
could recognize that I didn't even give
it to you but it came out I guess cause
like I [ __ ] up there was this report
that said vaping causes the same harm as
smoking cigarettes oh really
paid for by whom but a cigarette company
but now it has been redacted
hey redact that [ __ ] or retracted is
that this [ __ ] doesn't matter though
because stupid people will remember the
first study and never hear the debunked
stuff oh wait what about the kids that
are getting like hospitalized what are
they getting hospitalized for okay that
is different because that one is the
vitamin E thing I mean the vitamin E is
what's causing the respiratory damages
but this exact study here that was
published the this one is saying that it
is the exact same like similar with
smoking cigarettes incorrect because it
turns out this was a peer-reviewed study
and once the peers started reviewing the
actual data they were like wait you
can't you didn't even use this proper
data the data that they were using they
were saying some people would get the
same effects from smoking cigarettes
from vaping even before they started
vaping so that's like what that makes no
sense so that's when maybe they live in
a secondhand smoke place so just
constantly getting that bad stuff well
no they were actual smokers too I think
the study was done by UC Riverside
students in their first year have you
heard the phrase liking it halfway
around the world before the truth can
get its pants on that's basically what
happened heard it now and I like it I
like it no I was with you it was during
the Christmas season I was with some
family and one of my [ __ ] uncles who
I wish was here right now was talking
about how bad vaping is I'm not even a
vapor person and I was like no this
shit's [ __ ] like this current the
vaping study everyone's talking about
and pushing and there was a couple of
deaths from vaping too and like compared
to like what people die of all the time
like the vaping deaths were very minimal
mmm but but they start pushing this this
propaganda in the news and on all media
was like fate being so bad for you it's
gonna kill you it can kill you and now
that's all debunked but but idiots like
my uncle are like no it's not completely
so the whole situation here is that this
paper was published by the American
Heart Association scientific journal
claiming that vaping could lead to a
heart attack the same as smoking
cigarettes and the thing is like I had
said before like they were using weird
data and it's not that it's just that
because of the data that they were using
it can't really fully back up the claims
that they were making with the reason
why they had to retract that study and
and so the conclusion here is that
they're saying that yes if you smoke
cigarettes and if you vape obviously
you're gonna have problems but the whole
thing here is like just solidifying and
focusing on vape only to lead to heart
attacks they're saying that they can
back that up but that's what the news
did right yeah it was just vaping wall
to wall we're like we need to get the
competition out of here oh yeah yeah
yeah because the guy that was publishing
this they're saying that he was backed
by tobacco industry oh yeah I bet you if
they did a study of if bullying siblings
can cause heart attacks they'll find
more [ __ ] evidence within
cigarettes you know it's crazy though
this tobacco industry being like hey
that shit's bad for you the ball man
people don't even know that the tobacco
industry they their genius [ __ ] mark
Mac marketers back in a day they would
[ __ ] have doctors tell you that it's
healthy to smoke a cigarette we didn't
paid the best [ __ ] doctors and it was
like yeah it doesn't do anything and I
have a doctor and a [ __ ] suit smoking
in a commercial that's crazy
no you know what yes bro you know what
I'll kill you [ __ ] shark-attack dude
you can have him anything oh yeah yeah
[ __ ] we'll get you man
always looking up they look so cool it
looks cool it's the market it is a
martini but it works it's so nasty it
smells bags you don't know about your
parking at the actual way of doing it
yeah all that like the smelling bad when
your coffee your teeth the flesh there's
a real ways what's so creepy but what's
so genius about the marketing is that
it's so cool that even in movies if you
need to write someone to look cool
you would've said and then if you see
someone can't contain their smoke the
the Sidra is the gold standard now this
guy's a [ __ ] you know you don't go you
don't go smoking is unsexy you go this
[ __ ] is a [ __ ] you guys
watching that [ __ ] euphoria show an
11 year old kid smoking I'm like he's
cool burning yeah I can hear it tomorrow
yeah well we all ride to these
conclusions naturally I'm sure we didn't
have any undue influence think about
double-oh-seven right you think that
[ __ ] could run away and catch
fools being a [ __ ] smoker I was a
smoker for so many [ __ ] years I'm
like [ __ ] after that
running [ __ ] no dude I'm gonna die do or
bond laying a cigarette he likes a
$5,000 cigarette and he's gonna run
after a guy I'd be [ __ ] 20 put the
cigar my mouth I might as the $5,000
cigar dude I'm not [ __ ] [ __ ] die
after that true true in real life that's
the worst marketing ever dude have you
guys ever seen a guy that smokes that
could also do the splits can't say all
right but I've never seen someone
smoking and doing gymnastics at the same
time either cuz I was thinking you're
right Joe people that smoke aren't that
fit so I'm like someone that can do the
splits I've never seen him smokin if you
imagine it bad damn remember blood sport
that [ __ ] doing a split scene
and he has a [ __ ] cigarette in his
mouth
and he's like that's that new marketing
yeah I've never witnessed somebody
smoking while doing long division so
maybe that [ __ ]
tops you from doing math oh wait maybe I
did oh no no no that no hunting he were
that are a beautiful mind I never know
that
I feel like there there are scenes of
professors or geniuses like smoke in and
inner [ __ ] it back there all the [ __ ]
talk more like this they're like they
probably got the genius and the smells
afterwards yeah dude you put a scientist
in front of a [ __ ] and metal
container with a [ __ ] alien in it and
put a cigarette in his mouth I'm like
that's one of the coolest things like
this cuz I know why that [ __ ]
smoked and he's like yeah
boy you buggin finest scientists that
found an alien that smokes cigarettes
you're like all these [ __ ] no wonder
they capture this alien this
[ __ ] aliens cool [ __ ] oh yeah
the cigars at the end cool yeah but the
alien smoking is a little bit cool yeah
beeping doesn't look as cool though not
at all the guy that does the [ __ ]
tricks yeah oh yeah you would geek it
looks at all smoking a cigarette look
[ __ ] cooler yeah that's true than that
[ __ ] that's not [ __ ] [ __ ] moisture
baby needs a rebrand dude we got to get
that James Bond smoker doing vaping my
friend's brother is like a professional
vapor right as soon as that [ __ ]
blow smoke on the table crackling Wow
and I want to slap his [ __ ] face cuz
he does this [ __ ] where the whole table
and it he just [ __ ] does art and [ __ ]
they [ __ ] go high like that why
they're also annoying about bro but it
looks so cool or have you seen the [ __ ]
where they've even see like bubbles and
yeah Bobby
oh yeah there's fools that do like a
circle and they shoot a [ __ ] arrow
through that side or like a heart and
then I love it why can't they work that
harder than job
hey the guy I follow has a chameleon
followers and he's getting brand deals
and through it like shooting me it's
like a it's like an amateur magician
right that's a [ __ ] geek but now this
guy just wears like [ __ ] boy clothes so
when he does that I want to [ __ ]
smack them into action he's like wait do
that again that's how I smack him in the
back of the head yeah see you know I
defended vapours and yet I can I still
hate him that's how fair I am that's
true you're not biased it's crazy how
fast that that's stigma around them kind
of spread though you know I'm saying
because I felt like vaping became
popular and then all of a sudden it was
like you're douchey if you do that you
know I'm saying oh the respiratory
problems happen too
it's the cocky [ __ ] though man it's this
[ __ ] it's like this and then because it
smells good they think we all want to
smell I mean it smells baaaad and they
appreciate sometimes but the other times
I'm like you [ __ ] [ __ ] you think
you're so important that you could just
put all this air out look like I don't
want smelly used to you used to be okay
to do it everywhere in the airplanes
when they first came out I was vaping
for like a couple months I did it out of
poker table I did it indoors it was so
cool cuz there was no rules against it
yeah and now it's like no vapes no e
cigarettes no nothing cigars and
gambling is pretty cool
yes cigars and whiskey it slipped
there's a cigar and whiskey bar at
Caesar's Palace and it's like you feel
so just fancy gentleman like I'm pretty
down for that I'm down for that tube I
mean
cigars is all about flavor right you
don't even hail it you don't inhale it
yeah fill [ __ ] you up favors still
gross yeah my end of it your tongue is
burnt like a [ __ ] so you're just
like I'm cool man I'm rich yeah and then
halfway through the cigar you're like
guys I don't yeah let's stop like your
stomach hurts
you like the nokia [ __ ] outfits
stings yeah I was I got [ __ ] buzzed
off a cigar when we went to the strip
club in Vegas
did you I got buzzes [ __ ] cigars yeah we
were smoking cigars and I just know it
ate your Wyatt
five the cigar is bounced around yeah
you miss what Joe just said what is it
who's that we smoked a cigar
I just remembered seeing titties I've
ever seen in weight amenities I got
burned down I'll tell you one time I was
in Vegas at a strip club but it was so
late in life we were drunken at the club
and I remember it's like I was getting a
lap dance and then I woke up the
stripper was asleep I was asleep
security guy was like hey and we're like
I like this and she was in my arms
middle ab dances they're both like Oh
Cher's like five minutes fall asleep
yeah do you get charged like eight songs
yeah you've been here for three hours
[Laughter]
that sucks
well going back to the whole east
cigarette thing they were saying that
this publication ended up rising more
concerns about using e-cigarettes which
is continuing a misconception of the
life-saving potential from switching
from cigarettes to vaping so that's like
why the entire scientific community was
like what the hell man like we're
supposed to be standing by the truth and
facts and you're just spreading this
misinformation and the spreading fear
over something that could be life-saving
if you would switch from smoking
cigarettes to baby so it is better
they're saying that if you switch over
worse the tobacco industry hmm don't
want that damn and I think one of the
problems of people reading the articles
too is the danger of these articles is
sometimes they'll summarize it and they
put their own agenda in it so nothing
really beats you looking at the study
yourself which is also available but
it's more boring I know it's more boys a
bunch of numbers and stats and stuff but
you won't be able to be you want
misinterpret it less because a lot of
these companies have their own agenda so
they just read a couple things that put
it together and they're over summarizing
things and they're misleading well you
also have to really read the study to
because there's a bunch of them out
there about diet coke that say that it
leads to obesity because but when you
read it it's not because of your drink
of the act of drinking diet coke it's
because the the sweetness and your mouth
makes you crave more sweetness and so
people find themselves wanting to eat
cake or whatever or pie or whatever
really
not because the diet coke so that's why
you gotta read this [ __ ] after really
read because it's not about like oh if I
just drink the diet coke I'm getting fat
I thought it was because fat people
choose that coke they do they definitely
say I bottles because like you know you
drink diet you're doing diet coke so you
like you're me I'm drinking diet coke I
can eat more food
yeah right so many Tings it's all that
we used to drink
[Music]
[Music]